ottawa le répète sur tous les tons
depuis des mois pas de péage pas de pont
hors québec a voulu quantifier l'impact
d'un éventuel le péage sur le nouveau
pont champlain
notre bureau de québec a obtenu ces
chiffres voici david gentil depuis des
mois ottawa martèle qu'il y aura un
péage sur le pont champlain mais des
estimations faites en début d'année par
transports québec prévoit des impacts
majeurs les chiffres obtenus par radio
canada indiquent qu'un tarif de 3
dollars environ 6000 véhicules de plus
se dirigerait vers les quatre autres
accès concrètement c'est une hausse de
l'achalandage de 25% sur le pont
victoria et de 13% sur le pont jacques
cartier
les impacts sont exacerbées dans le cas
d'un coût de 5 $ 60
c'est environ 13000 véhicules qui se
dirigerait vers les quatre autres accès
au projet alors une augmentation de
presque 50% sur le pont victoria et de
plus de 20% sur le pont jacques cartier
dans les deux scénarios le tunnel louis
hippolyte la fontaine et le pont merci
verrait également l'achalandage
augmenter de manière importante
l'impact serait donc majeur estime-t-on
à transports québec on parle même de
déplacement potentiellement deux fois
plus long qu'à l'heure actuelle le
canton
ça va congestionne et les enfants
jusqu'à ma retraite vont porter leurs
papiers
principal avantage une fluidité accrue
sur le pont champlain pour ceux qui
décideraient de payer au tarif de 3
dollars le nombre de véhicules baisse du
tiers tandis qu'à 5 $ 60
ces six voitures sur 10 qui disparaître
alors vous voyez bien que ça n'a pas de
bon sens on peut pas régler
asseyez de régler un problème en en
créant un autre ailleurs ces
informations et de comprendre pourquoi
le gouvernement marois était si
farouchement opposé aux péages
les spécialistes du gouvernement ne
peuvent évaluer précisément combien
d'automobilistes se résoudrait avec le
temps à payer pour rouler sur champlain
ni combien d'entre eux déciderait en
bout de ligne de se tourner vers les
transports en commun ici david gentilles
pas au canada québec françois cormier
vous avez les réactions des deux
ministres concernés denis lebel au
fédéral bien sûr et robert poëti ouais
les deux ministres qui se rencontraient
vous le savez il y avait tout un mystère
entourant cette rencontre on voulait pas
nous donner l'heure ni le lieu
finalement on les a trouvés et on les a
questionnés sur ces chiffres obtenus par
le collègue jean tilly scottage fédérale
ben on utilise on en est conscient qu'il
y aura des impacts mais il faut le payer
ce pont et il y aura un péage du côté du
provincial on nous dit sans commenter
les chiffres directement bien évidemment
que c'est justement le genre de chiffres
dont ils ont besoin pour convaincre le
fédéral que le péage n'a pas de bon sens
et le ministre poëti estime qu'il a
encore quatre ans pour convaincre le
fédéral de ne pas mettre de péage sur le
pont champlain
on peut coûter les deux politiciens bien
sûr qu'on y priori fait par tout ce qui
se passe mais je pense la population de
montréal est préoccupé qui ait pas de
nouveau pont et quel prochain en plein
actuelle ne puisse continuer plusieurs
années donc l'important pour la
population de montréal c'est qu'un pense
bâtissent pour leur permettre de
continuer à circuler du goûter
c'est ce genre de schaeffler qu'il faut
trouver il faut construire pour
démontrer au gouvernement fédéral que de
régler le pont champlain de cette
façon-là pourrait causer des problèmes
majeurs à l'économie de montréal parce
qu'il ya des gens qui auraient peut-être
pas ces moyens là de se payer sur une
base quotidienne pour les travailler
payer un péage robert poëti le ministre
québécois donc a dû en parler lors de
cette rencontre en privé avec denis
lebel absolument il en a parlé mais ils
ont parlé de plusieurs autres dossiers
et si à l'exécuter là tout va bien dans
le meilleur des mondes ils s'entendent
sur à peu près tous les points
sauf donc la question du pont champlain
alors monsieur politis peau et estime
qu'il lui reste du temps pour convaincre
le ministre fédéral et le gouvernement
harper au complet et je vous mentionne
patrice en terminant la parlant du
gouvernement québécois que demain
rencontre importante entre philippe
couillard régis labeaume et denis
coderre concernant les régimes de
retraite
ça va se passer donc sur l'heure du
dîner à québec dossiers importants pour
les employés municipaux comme vous le
savez on va suivre ça bien sûr merci
françois au revoir au revoir